Led licht hat ausgerechnet
Gravierende schädliche folgen warnt ein forschungsteam aus potsdam die erde wird immer
Heller die folgen davon dass die nacht zunehmend verschwindet es sind nicht nur deutlich weniger
sternzeichen ende zu sehen sondern auch tiere und wir menschen bekommen das zu spüren wie genau und was jeder einzelne von uns
Gegen die zunehmende lichtverschmutzung tun kann jetzt den klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Vielen dank für die zahlreichen genesungswünsche
ich denke ich bin wieder auf dem aufsteigenden ast
Fakt ist wir menschen machen die erde nicht nur wärmer wir machen sie auch heller
genau das zeigen jetzt ergebnisse eines forschungsteams vom geoforschungszentrum potsdam
dabei stützen sie sich auf messergebnisse des us-satelliten sony ngp
der ein radiometer an bord hat den 820 kilometern
Höhe misst er sowohl das licht das wir menschen sehen können als auch die für uns unsichtbaren emissionen die sich
Im nahen infrarotbereich befinden die daten auflösung liegt bei 750 metern die
Weltweite nicht verschmutzung kann somit sehr genau erfasst werden und trotzdem das problem der zunehmenden
Helligkeit wird von der aktuellen studie eher unter als überschätzt denn das messgerät sony ngp
Miss licht mit wellenlänge von 500 nanometern aufwärts neuere leds beinhalten mittlerweile aber bereits licht mit wellenlängen unter diesem wert
Das ist also noch nicht in diesen messungen enthalten die ergebnisse der studie in den letzten fünf jahren haben sowohl die bestrahlten fläche
als auch die intensität der künstlichen beleuchtung
zugenommen jeweils mindestens um zwei prozent dieser trend ist fast in allen ländern zu beobachten
Abgesehen von regionen dieser welt in den krieg herrscht so wie etwa in syrien oder dem jemen ein weiteres ergebnis des potsdamer
Forschungsteams die zunahme der lichtverschmutzung entspricht in etwa dem maß in dem auch das bruttosozialprodukt
eines landes wächst in industrieländern ist dies etwas langsamer der fall als in schwellen- oder
Entwicklungsländern schuld daran sind eben die leds selbst wenn sie in der anschaffung erst einmal teurer sind als klassische
natriumdampflampen gelten sie als langlebiger
zudem auch als heller und gleichzeitig die sparen dementsprechend wird weltweit
Umgerüstet städte firmen und privatleute setzen zunehmend auf diese art der beleuchtung hier vermutet das potsdamer forschungsteam den
sogenannten rebound effekt eigentlich wenn man etwas gutes tun doch das verkehrt sich dann ins gegenteil
die wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler gehen davon aus dass durch den zunehmenden einsatz von
Led licht jetzt auch orte und dinge beleuchtet werden die früher nicht
beleuchtet worden sind mögliche einsparungen werden also durch den
zusätzlichen einsatz von leds sowie dazu nicht gemacht und sogar
überkompensiert zitat obwohl einzelne projekte energie
einsparen wird der einspareffekt durch neue projekte auf rezept das sagt einer der beteiligten forscher christoph huber
vergleichbar mit einem autofahrer der sich ein extra
umweltfreundliches modell kauft das wenig benzin verbraucht dann aber weitere strecken zurücklegt und somit der natur schadet auch ein beispiel für diesen
Rebound effekt die folgen also des steigenden led einsatzes die nacht verschwindet die erde wird heller
gravieren für nachtaktive tiere die sich so immer schlechter orientieren können aber auch störungen in der
fortpflanzung wir im hormonhaushalt oder der nahrungssuche
Können die folgen sein und auch für uns menschen ist der wechsel von tag und nacht
also helligkeit und dunkelheit enorm wichtig doch
Led-licht gaukelt uns beispielsweise in der nacht vor er sei bereits morgen und so kann unsere innere uhr aus dem gleichgewicht
Geraten und darüber haben wir ja hier erst vor kurzem
Im rahmen der nobelpreis woche berichtet die innere uhr hat deutlich mehr einfluss auf den menschlichen körper als sie vielleicht denken mag
Wenn die zellen aller lebewesen reagieren sehr sensibel auf veränderungen wie die folge von
Hell und dunkel warm und kalt die körpertemperatur steigt und sinkt beispielsweise
Und auf unser hormonspiegel ändert sich wir alle kennen diese art jetlag gefühl durch die, zeitumstellung
Im frühjahr wenn wir plötzlich eine stunde früher aufstehen müssen und der stoffwechsel durcheinander gerät fatale
also, welche konsequenzen die zunehmende lichtverschmutzung
Für alle lebewesen auf der erde haben könnte doch die gute nachricht jeder von uns kann etwas dagegen machen und das ist gar nicht
Mal so schwer wer uns das problem erst einmal bewusst machen und das licht
ausschalten wenn wir es gerade eben nicht benötigen der erste schritt schon einmal getan der kanton zürich hat noch mehr tipps zusammengefasst
grundsätzlich ist es besser wenn man das licht von oben nach unten
ausrichtet und nicht umgekehrt sieht tatsächlich auch das nicht präzise
zu lenken oder es präzise zu steuern beispielsweise indem man einen bewegungsmelder
Verwendet aber es gibt auch noch einen weiteren tipp von christoph huber aus dem potsdamer
forschungsteam für die meisten von uns ist nicht etwas dass da ist und über das man sich keine gedanken gemacht aber
Wenn es da eine lampe in ihrer stadt gibt die sie stört
Zum beispiel weil sie zu hell ist rufen sie ihre stadtwerke an und vielleicht
Könnt ihr dann was tun wenn er kein video zum thema noch
Zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann durch meliert ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Auf die glocke hier geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken smarthome die zukunft des lebens mit noch mehr infos dazu
Wie man bequemer leben und sparen kann und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran